jurors in the Harvey Weinstein trial
will likely be re-examining witness
testimony during their deliberations
this morning the disgraced media mogul
left court in New York yesterday with
the help of that Walker he's been using
the jurors asked the judge yesterday to
rehear evidence which is always an
interesting request our national
correspondent Rico Duncan has been
following the trial for us freaka good
morning so do we know what they want to
review well they're taking their time
asking questions so far the jury has
come back with five notes the most
recent request focused heavily on
Annabella shoe or the former Sopranos
actress almost one month ago she hora
testified the Hollywood mogul shoved her
onto her bed in the early 1990s and
raped her yesterday jurors asked for all
emails from to and regarding Shore and
to review testimony from she ORS friend
actress Rosie Perez Perez said on the
stand that she hora confided in her
about the alleged rape but that she was
too afraid to go to the police the jury
also asked to rehear testimony from Mimi
Hill a the former production assistant
who says she was assaulted by Weinstein
twice in 2006
now after yesterday's proceedings
hallets attorney Gloria Allred said she
believes the jury asking to revisit
testimony is a positive sign Weinstein's
legal team which was hit with a gag
order on Tuesday tried to get the judge
to silence Allred as well they claimed
her talking to the media could influence
the jury the judge denied that request
saying he does not have the authority to
grant in yeah it's really hard to tell
what the jury's thinking but you can
certainly say they are taking their time
well there's a lot of very carefully
which is a good time all right Joe Rica
thank you